[Music]
welcome back to the true Jordy YouTube
channel subscribe and like the video if
you haven't already now about a month
ago we covered the case of Tupac's
murder in which Kefi D was arrested and
it was seen in multiple interviews to be
pointing the finger at P didy saying
this is the guy who offered me all the
money to go and get it done and clearly
Kefi D didn't feel like the money had
been delivered apparently P didy does
have money for his ex who has just
launched a $30 million lawsuit at him
for a lot of horrible things and somehow
within 24 hours P dides came up with a
cash and settled I'm not saying he's
guilty but he settled it quicker than
Michael Jackson settled with the first
kid who accused him make of that what
you will now in terms of what he's
actually accused of let's get into the
details because after this you ain't
going to be listening to bad boys for
life and nodding your head the same way
I Love More Money More Problems it's a
great song I don't like him anymore now
the document with all of the allegations
is 35 page is long and has a trigger
warning on the front we're not going to
get into every single thing but I'm
going to give you the main bits
obviously some of you remember Cassie
from the big single she had produced by
P didy me and you she had a few uh big
singles she was a star on the rise among
some of the serious allegations were
that P did he sex trafficked Cassie uh
to male prostitutes to fulfill his
voyerism fantasies in hotels at his home
now he met this girl when she was young
and he's sitting there basically
masturbating and forcing her to do this
with these guys while he films it when
she tried to leave him he ried her often
he would punch beat kick and stomp on
her resulting in bruises burst lips
black eyes and bleeding so after that
relationship ended she was romantically
involved with kid CI uh did he threaten
to blow his car up now you're thinking
all right bit dramatic his car actually
did blow up a few days later so connect
the dots as part of the psychological
pressure he would also make her carry
his gun in her purse when they'd go to
events and stuff like that which he
didn't want to do he also got her hooked
on drugs because he himself wanted those
drugs so he would then get her hooked on
them and make her go and collect the
prescriptions so what a guy when he met
ush she was 19 and he was 37 he signed
out of the record label and basically
just had complete and utter control over
her entire life so Not only was she in a
romantic relationship he also
essentially owned her as an artist and
he's famous for treating his artists
like [__] she would have been no
exception to that and just going back to
the prostitution thing it wasn't like
that would just be for one night either
this apparently lasted days while the
drug Bender just carried on going and
going it wouldn't have been over quickly
for her so he would call these escapades
freak offs and he would tell her that
this was our little secret no one can
know and by the end of it she would be
in such a bad way that she would need an
IV with fluids just to recover from them
now ordinarily I'd refrain from saying
if I think this is true or not because
at the end of the day I wasn't there I
don't know but the man paid her off in
record time that is not a coincidence
and this woman was with him for a long
time and when you look at the character
of p over the years he's always been
power mad in every way he treats his
artists like slaves even biggie was the
star of the show the center of attention
the gangster and P did he couldn't help
but Force his way in to the Limelight
always even shog Knight made a joke
about it like you know you want a real
record producer who doesn't want to be
all in the videos come to me because
this guy is trying to steal you
Spotlight so he's definitely power mod
and cussy isn't even the first woman
he's been with to accuse him of this
sort of [__] his ex-girlfriend Gina also
accused him of stomping on her stomach
and punching her in the head in 2019 she
said she was repeatedly physically
assaulted we were in his cin he like
pushed me and I fell to the ground and
um and then he got he like stood over
me so I was like laying on my back and
he stood over me and he started like
punching me like this like he avoided my
face but he like started punching me
like on the side of my head and I was
just like covering my face and
um he did that he did that and then and
then after he got done doing that he
like cuz he was standing his legs were
like St in between me so he like he like
stomped on my
stomach like really hard and I like took
the wind out of my breath I couldn't
even I couldn't breathe and he kept but
he kept hitting me and I was like
pleading to him like can you just can
you stop I can't breathe and he like
stopped for a little bit he um he like
grabbed my hair from the back and like
was
um like punching the back of my head
horrible to listen to that this girl was
also 21 at the time that she met him she
was with him for 5 years and there is an
overlap between her and Cassie I think
you were seeing them both at the same
time so literally beating up both these
young women I mean the guy's a lunatic
and his old security guard has also
spoke out about his problems being
violent with women it was always abuse
between those two physically but Kim got
tired of and she wasn't taking her if he
put his hands on her she was going at
him so The Bodyguard makes a reference
to this lady here this is Kim Porter who
was ped his baby mama she was getting
beaten up by him she'd had enough of it
she actually fought back with a CO screw
and managed to take a chunk out of his
arm so well done to her it's a
horrendous situation for these
when it comes to Kim Porter it seems
like when she was alive he was probably
taking her for granted and after she
passed away he have a regret like man
when she was alive I should have you
know been in a full committed
relationship with her it seems like he
got a lot of regret when it comes to Kim
Porter now that face that that that
bodyguard isn't buying any of it bro
come on stop the [__] man he got you
fool too huh you know say Kim know all
his deepest
secrets you understand Kim knew why he
was using the butt
plugs
Man Kim probably told all that [__] in
her book you understand that up and got
missing the day she
died you understand what I'm
saying see I could say that because I
used to see them in action with other
couples and other people you understand
what I'm saying I was told to watch the
door this is taking the turn Kim had
been writing a tell all book about pay
Diddy and then suddenly from pneumonia
now her friends have come out since then
and said that they completely believe P
Diddy was in some way behind her death
because let's be real if this man is
such a psycho that he's not afraid to
beat the crap out of his own women in
his life then if you're going to expose
him to the world it's either going to be
him or you in a cycle like that's mind
and it's not going to be him so I
wouldn't be surprised if he did kill her
we've seen with the Tupac situation
there is no length this man won't go to
to get what he wants let alone protect
himself that's an easy decision in the
mind of a nutcase like him in my opinion
now that's pure speculation but whatever
she was writing was never released so
there's definitely a reason to wonder
even going back to the death of the
Notorious BIG there is speculation there
because prior to Biggie's death Lil CES
who was biggy's best friend said he
wasn't happy he wasn't happy with the
money he was getting he wanted to set up
his own record label cuz that's where
the real money is and apparently P Diddy
had bought the publishing rights to the
notorious Big's whole album collection
so he has invested in Biggie's stock and
when Biggie died the album sales went
through the roof not one person on
planet Earth benefited more financially
from the death of the notorious Pig than
P didy the motive was there I'm not
saying he actually did Kill the guy but
there's enough reason to wonder and in
fact most of the artist P did he's work
with have said the guy is like a slave
driver right like you get minimal return
for maxim him eff and he crams
everything even mace who you've seen
perform with P didd countless times he
got [__] by the guy and this is the
someone who's supposed to be his friend
and only recently has P didy all of a
sudden relinquished the publishing back
to the artists when he's had Decades of
creaming in all the profits it's like
using it all up till it's not even worth
anything anymore and then go there you
go and this bodyguard who worked for py
has actually spoken out about what py
was saying about Tupac and big and the
idea of them dying before even happened
he said um I'm a businessman I'm about
making money
but something got to change I don't give
a [__] if Pac gota die big Gotta Die or
Su Knight go to jail something's got to
change and he took upstairs he took he
turned around and walked back upstairs
and it didn't dawn on me what he said
and then my man looked at me and Bun was
like yo that
said big and the wildest thing about
that quote is Suge ended up in jail p
and big died everything that pet did he
wanted from the scenario that he just
plucked out a thin air and sometimes
when people do that it's because that's
what he's craving so again more reason
to wonder and it's a well-known fact
that P did had like off duty police
officers on the payroll doing security
with him so it's the only logical reason
why PDD has not been fully investigated
for either of these murders I don't know
how much longer this guy can keep the w
from the door because you've now got
multiple women coming forward you've got
key D the guy who literally was in the
car when Tupac was killed saying P didd
he was the one who offered us the money
how is this man still a free man the
answer is money he's clearly paying
everyone and anyone off just like he's
done with Cassie and here's another
story of P didy flexing his power on
Cassie KY right here then jumped off the
B came over and say yo yo
Cassie
tomorrow I want you to shave the side of
your head
and I was
like I like what the [__] kind of
request is
that like so when I'm like what the [__]
so when I look up there this white woman
side of her head was shaved my [__] and
the [__] look good with it so I was
looking the cast I was like well I I was
like you not about to do that are you
she said well I mean whatever Shan wants
I'm going to do in the grand scheme of
things I know that this isn't that isn't
the worst thing ever in the world but it
just adds to the story line that we're
hearing is is being painted from every
different angle of this woman would just
do whatever he told her to she had no
individuality left by the time the sky
was done with her and he has P he
talking with Cassie back in the day
about how he's such a supportive record
producer when you sign somebody that's
young you have to be there with them
through their ups and their downs home
girl Cassie right here she had a a semi
no I would say it was a whack show she
had a whack she had a pretty whack Show
on BET you know um did not perform at
the level of the bad boy Excellence
literally just disrespecting that openly
in front of our face with no FKS given
it does get worse it's very important
that youall understand that bad boy we
with our artists through their growth
period through their bad shows through
their good shows you know we we love
them when they records are hot we love
them when they trip and fall and bad boy
we there for people do ups and downs so
many record label artists from Bad Boy
have come out and sued him complained I
don't think you can find an artist with
a good word to say about this guy is it
cra that you're on me because you're
talking [__] he's just a [__] [__]
isn't he and and actually for women he
seems like their worst nightmare because
he's inescapable he doesn't just get his
clothes into them in a relationship
sense he literally owns them as an
artist as well God knows what this must
have been like for this poor girl thank
God this got settled quickly because as
much as I want to see this guy get
Justice someday I don't know if she
would have had the strength to go
through a lawsuit against this guy he's
a real piece of [__] this clip is taken
from an interview with Kirk burrow who
was the president of Bad Boy
Entertainment literally helped build the
company into what it was with P Diddy
and I'll not play the whole clip for you
but as you can see by the title here
they weren't best friends like puffy
claims he's lying about the relationship
this was a thing that P didy did post
death to I think help his own celebrity
like the more I play into I'm Big's best
friend and it's really hurting me that
he's dead the more people will empathize
with me and the more I'll then get some
of that cachier that big he had as a
celebrity it's for his own benefit as
was help building the career of big for
his own benefit this wasn't charity and
it never is with pay and the guy also
goes on to explain that he himself who
had 25% ownership in bad boy was forced
to relinquish that top did he through
being threatened that he had a room full
of people with bats in their hand saying
either your face or your name is going
to be on the contract so give me my 25%
pay did he is not the best guy to go in
the business with and the ironic thing
is is although he paid paid Cassie's
claim off within 24 hours of it going in
initially he put out a statement saying
he vly deny these offensive and
outrageous allegations and yet just less
than 24 hours later had a change of
heart turns out they're actually
actually pretty bang on then better
better pay this it's just too much smoke
yeah man Jean resurfaced where Jean
spoke about how he used to put paws on
his baby mama and then girlfriend Misa
Hilton I mean this is just it's
ridiculous now cuz I'm I'm literally
going down and seeing more video clips
of other women this is another baby mama
who another bodyguard has said that he
seen P did he beating her up insane how
does this guy stay out of trouble and I
guess we'll round this up by showing a
little clip from P did's time on making
the band was an MTV show where a group
of kids were trying to be scouted by him
as talent and as part of it he told them
that they had to walk 6 hours to get him
some cheesecake I'm starving too you
know something I want me a piece of
cheesecake
from you know where to get the
cheesecake spiders at yeah yeah and
y'all can walk from here get the
cheesecake see the city enjoy the sights
would you it's not about me trying to do
a mean spirited initiation hazing act to
them it's a bigger picture to it um in
the world of music I got to get up every
day and do a bunch of I don't want to do
I got to bite my tongue and I got to do
it with a smile on my
face but I do want some cheesecake
somebody going quit somebody ain't got
the heart the stamina to be bad boy
somebody Ain got the passion the
driveing what a prick that was P Diddy
and all of the details surrounding the
allegations about him let me know what
your thoughts are in the comments below
and if you haven't already hit that like
button subscribe to the true Jord
YouTube channel and I'll see you on the
next
one